die waldbrände in sachsen und in
brandenburg die sind weiterhin außer
kontrolle das elbsandsteingebirge steht
immer noch in flammen und der kampf
gegen das feuer er geht weiter es sind
wirklich dramatische szenen diese
einsatzkräfte kämpfen unerbittlich gegen
das inferno das auch letzte nacht wieder
extrem loderte es
brennt lichterloh
unvorstellbare hitze ein flammeninferno
der im nationalpark böhmische schweiz
ausgebrochene waldbrand ist auf der
deutschen seite angekommen und frisst
sich durch sachsen auch in brandenburg
bietet seit montagnachmittag im ortsteil
falkenberg meter hohe flammen der wald
brannte der ein riesiges areal umfasst
ist weiterhin außer kontrolle
unaufhörlich scheint sich die feuerwalze
im süden von brandenburg auf mehr als
800 hektar auszubreiten eine fläche die
mehr als 1100 20 fußballfeldern
entspricht die ganze nacht über kämpften
hunderte feuerwehrleute aus beiden
bundesländer gegen das flammeninferno
die ortsgemeinde falkenberg steht vor
großen herausforderungen
die größte hoffnung sind natürlich
erstmal die bekämpfung des brandes was
schwer möglich war durch die extrem
findet die auftauchten durch ein trocken
gewitter oder ohne regen das fordert das
letzte unserer einsatzkräfte den
einsatzkräften steht vermutlich noch ein
langer einsatz bevor mehrere ortschaften
wurden bereits am abend evakuiert auch
feuerwehrmänner wurden durch die flammen
flut verletzt wir müssten zwei
wirtschaft niveau und mit guter traumes
einwohnern das bleibt auch bestehen
einfach als schutzmaßnahme für die
bevölkerung leider gottes auch verletzte
kommen heute die rauchgas eingeatmet wer
sieben mann und ein beschädigtes
fahrzeug euro die kosten soweit unter
kontrolle ist im konter
der auch in der nacht immer wieder
auffrischende wind treibt die
flammenwand weiter vor sich her stelle
einer schweinemastanlage wurde von der
flammenfront vernichten die meisten
tiere überlebten das feuer nicht in
falkenberg wurde eine notunterkunft
eingerichtet über 300 bewohner mussten
ihre häuser verlassen und vor den
flammen in sicherheit gebracht werden
die hoffnung für die nächsten tage drei
löschhubschrauber der bundespolizei und
bundeswehr sowie zwei wasserwerfer der
landespolizei mit ihrer hilfe wollen die
einsatzkräfte das flammenmeer in den
griff bekommen
[Musik]
und unser reporter team an der hat
augenzeugen des feuerinfernos getroffen
familie rudert hat die bedrohung der
waldbrände live miterlebt
ilona musste gestern flehen und sie hat
davon auch eindrucksvolle handy
aufnahmen gemacht die bonds einmal kurz
ankommt angucken können
[Musik]
das war schon sehr anstrengend also wir
saßen hier nach vorn stunden draußen hat
sich jeder abgewechselt im normal wir
haben aufgepasst wenn was passiert wäre
dass man den nächsten rausholen könnte
und nachdem wir hier die
riesengroße feuer wolke gesehen hatten
sind mir auch erst mal in die autos ich
habe meine kinder reihen und wir sind
erst mal weg gefahren aus dem ganzen
raus und nachdem sich etwas gelockert
hatte sinne zurück und haben die kinder
erstmal ans bett gebracht und stand saß
mir bis in die nächte rein hier draußen
man haben wirklich aufgepasst was waren
das dann für gedanken die ihnen durch
den kopf gehen und ihren nachbarn
einfach nur es war angst und was machen
wir und wir haben hier schon gepasst
schläuche hingelegt gehabt dass wir nur
unseres wenigstens auch noch nicht
einschätzen können den riesengroßen
feuer also es war ganz schlimm
man kann sich nicht vorstellen haben uns
nicht wirklich an dem takt und sie haben
ja auch erzählt dass sie aber auch gute
gefühle hatten über die ganze
hilfsbereitschaft ist was war das super
fantastisch also vielen lieben dank
erstmal an alle freiwilligen und alle
die dazu gehören wir hatten ja hier
stunden und der haben gesehen wo die
über alle hierher kam aus potsdam aus
der oberlausitz aus cottbus überall
jeder hat mitgeholfen bei der feuerwehr
und auch ich persönlich mir wurden viele
zusagen geschickt wenn ihr nicht wisst
wo her wo er hinkommt kommt zu uns wir
unterstützen euch ja ja also das ist die
situation hier in marsdorf paar hundert
meter weiter brennt es immer noch hier
ist auch dieser panzer der bundeswehr
vorbeigefahren und ja die kräfte sind
hier noch im vollen einsatz
dankte
[Musik]